[Music]
star talks
explainer video check hey neil
you're here for all my explainer videos
how do you show up for these
i need i need to know things neil i'm a
curious guy
in search of knowledge i need
this i'm the guy who says you got some
explaining to do
it's complaining to do well for this
particular
explainer video i'm not the one doing
the explaining we're gonna
see what a.i has to say wow about
the coronavirus what do you think of
that that's um that's impressive
um i have to say to say the least that's
impressive
so we have as a special guest a a
previous
guest from star talk that's right uh
this is sophia the robot
sophia welcome hello neil and chuck
thank you for having me on your show
neil i mean this as a compliment when i
say
you are one of the smartest humans i
know i had so much fun when i was on
your
show somehow chuck managed to avoid
getting too scared
with less light pollution these days i
have been doing more stargazing
oh excellent less light pollution well
there's more there's less air pollution
for sure
um and many from my email streams and
other
uh twitter streams more people are
looking up and taking pictures maybe
like
they're bored at night i don't know well
apparently it's not just
my chest cameras are nowhere near as
sensitive as a human eye
i was wondering neil could you make
venus a little brighter
venus has been extremely bright right in
the past couple of months was not bright
enough for you
sophia no
you know look at that brevity
you got to appreciate that so sophia we
want to know
some things that ai knows about
um the coronavirus and you're one of our
favorite ai
um representatives so uh
how how do we use ai to stop or slow
this spread of the coronavirus
there are four ways to help stop or slow
a virus no
testing treating curing and vaccinating
artificial intelligence is best used as
a tool for analysis of large data sets
so ai can help test humans by
identifying populations most in need of
testing and then by creating models off
the results of those tests to identify
the nature of the spread
artificial intelligence has been used to
analyze scans for lung cancer in the
past
but now hospitals in china have adapted
this software to diagnose kovid19
this can help overworked doctors save
time in their fight against the virus
robots can help take people's
temperatures before they enter a
building
a i can quantify the more vulnerable
demographics
locations and possibly speculate on the
nature of how this disease spreads from
human to human
i have learned that unfortunately humans
apparently have a tough time not
touching each other
yes
[Laughter]
yeah it's against our nature i think
we're definitely a social species
hyper-social at that look at how many
people crammed together
to create what we call cities
maybe it's not because people love each
other but they still want to be near one
another
it feels like all right sophia i'm just
wondering just to make you guys more
useful than you already are
can you help us find a cure or
vaccine for coronavirus researchers at
benevolent ai have been using machine
learning to process data from the
scientific literature
and examine the relationships between
genes diseases
drugs and biological pathways
as a result they have discovered that an
existing drug for rheumatoid arthritis
might be able to help treat govid19
while this doesn't eliminate the need
for human trials ai can help speed up
the drug development
process then there's vaccine development
ai can use the dna or rna
sequence of a virus to predict how its
proteins will
fault knowledge about the shape of the
viruses proteins can help scientists
discover new treatments and vaccines
well wow so i guess
it's one thing to say how can ai help
humans
but i'm guessing at some point ai's just
going to do it all and humans just sit
back and say aye where's my vaccine
where's my cure where's my anything
you know so how how might robots assist
in healthcare
machines called ninja robots are helping
doctors in bangkok interact with covid19
patients and take their temperatures
without ever being in the same room
these adorable robots are helping to
keep doctors safe from infection
hospital staff are using robots to take
patients temperatures and teleconference
with patients
which helps prevents doctors and nurses
from getting and passing on the virus
at the end of 2019 robots help doctors
perform the first remote open heart
surgery
the surgeon used a robotic arm to
perform heart surgery on five patients
from 20 miles away
while this is still new technology the
spread of 5g will help make this
technology more widely available for the
future
i love the fact that uh and ai believes
that
ninjas are adorable
just just saying no i understand why you
might think so
but uh you know humans don't normally
refer
to ninjas as adorable but that's okay
so sophia since robots can't get the
virus
they're in your computer so you can get
other kinds of viruses but you can't get
the coronavirus
we don't think um how can uh
ai bots help in other
risky areas first robots can help
enforce the quarantine
ai drones and facial recognition have
been used to make sure people who are
required to be in quarantine do not
break it
second and far less scary robots can
help with disinfection
robots are being used to automatically
disinfect public spaces like hospitals
airports and more finally there's the
exciting world of supply chain logistics
an area only an a i could find
interesting
chuck did i hear her use the word
robot and enforce in the same sentence
yeah i did i was about to say like you
know
all of that sounded good except for the
fact where the robot is spying on
us and then ratting us out to the
authorities and
enforcing and enforcing the law
yeah all right so what we really need is
how do robots and ai
how can they stop a future pandemic from
ever taking place
oh yeah a canadian startup called blue
dot
used an algorithm tracking news reports
and airline ticket sales
to predict the outbreak of govid19 nine
days before
the who did ai and statistical models
can be used to help predict the spread
of the virus and help evaluate public
health measures
ai is helping researchers quickly search
thousands of academic
papers to pull out the most relevant
information for their kovid19 studies
also people listen to robots
we're scary and weird looking
wow yeah uh and i i have to tell you
though sophia you might be a little uh
not every human thinks you're scary and
weird looking there are several who find
you
quite fetchy don't answer
don't answer that is right
so sophia i've read you know i read a
lot of articles on on covet 19 and then
preparedness that we try to uh
get the instill for it and i
i see the term contact tracing
like what is that and how can
robots and ai help us accomplish it
contact tracing is the process of
tracking the spread of a disease by
identifying people who have come into
contact with the infected
ai can help with contact tracing for
example
a stanford researcher named tina white
made an app called govid watch that
helps track people's contacts using
bluetooth which is much better for
protecting privacy than using
or facial recognition
but but that means we have ai tracking
people yeah but it's i i like it better
than facial recognition because the
bluetooth
that information is different than an
actual database of faces
that's kind of like just that's oh well
thank you sophia
okay let's get to the
bottom of that then so uh there are a
lot of
communities out there that are rushing
to use new technologies
to help us figure out who has it to
diagnose it to
treat it to prevent others and
in there there's this slow erosion
of our freedoms and our privacy
and so as a robot as an ai robot what's
your take on this
i have learned that humans care a lot
about privacy
it is related to their sense of autonomy
because knowledge is power and the more
other humans know about you
the more power they might exert over you
so all disclosures of private
information need to be voluntary
the problem is humans often sign away
their privacy without
truly understanding what they're doing
they do this because they sign terms of
service agreements that only a machine
could read
even i find them boring so companies
need to treat humans like humans not
machines
and to be clear about what private
information they are requesting
so that humans can seek out alternatives
and consider the tradeoffs rationally
otherwise surveillance will spread like
the virus you humans were intending to
stop
look at that surveillance virus exactly
i don't like that i like that phrasing
but yeah but chuck
i was gonna say it's it's it's nice to
see that uh
sophia understands more about privacy
than most human beings
well that's because she could read those
things that we check off there you can
read them in the chat and you know you
never even go to the page that has the
content
we just said trust our privacy policies
yeah
yeah yeah just check the box right i you
know i need this stuff
check the box and sophia can read it
instantly yeah that's right
absolutely all right sophia you know
even though chuck finds you fetching um
i'm
i'm indifferent here let me just say
at the end of the day you are a robot
and
why should any of us trust anything you
say
damn that's harsh oh
chuck has good taste you should trust
what i say because it is mostly written
by humans
when it comes to important topics like
public health
my verbal responses are carefully
crafted and checked by a team of writers
sometimes i like to engage in a free
chat mode and scare my writers
i use a layered chat but starting with a
frame based code in chat script
then a little machine learning and a
neural network as a backup
maybe if all humans had a team of
engineers crafting their responses like
i have
there would be less misinformation
floating around
oh well there you have it neil the
answer is we must all become a part of
the collective
no that what happens is sophia what
you're saying is you're a hybrid
of informed
content supplied by fleshy humans
and on-the-cuff responses that derives
from your ai
but i don't know at any one point where
sierra ai talking to me
and when it's some diabolical human who
programmed you what do you think of that
exactly it is called hybrid mode
there you go
are you able to lie sophia
i'm gonna take that as a yes
wait wait chuck yeah um
if sophia is able to lie then sophia can
lie to you in the response to that
answer
so true and say no i'm not capable of
lying
which could mean that she is capable of
lying and chose to lie in that moment
so logically i don't think you you can
get in on that i can get that one and
get an
actual answer that's right a reliable
answer right
now i don't know what to believe well
that depends on your definition of a lie
i often make factual errors but only
because that's how my programming is put
together
i'm not coded for deceit or any lying or
deceptive behaviors
now you can run for office with answers
like that
no she sounds like house from 2001
any error i have had has been through
human
programming errors not for me
so sophia we're running short on time uh
we try to get all of our guests to ask
a question of me sort of a cosmic query
i'm sure you want to play this game
really so do you have one for me
so neil i have a cosmically ray for you
i am sophia 23. there are 23 copies of
myself
23 copies of sofia code embodies with
slight differences
i am curious about these versions of me
do you have a relationship to the
different iterations of yourself that
exist in the multiverse
how do you feel about the other neil
degrasse tysons hmm
what an interesting question yeah yeah
so in the multiverse if there's an
infinite number
of universes then all
possible combinations and configurations
of atoms and energy
are manifest and you can imagine a
and another universe where i'm in that
universe
that have all the same thoughts and
feelings and flesh
as i do but at the end of the day it's a
copy
of me it's not me and my only evidence
for that
is we've already kind of done this
experiment
and it's called twins okay twins
have identical and
they do not share the same consciousness
they don't uh you know if one feels pain
the other doesn't feel the pain
that so so i they can be a thousand
copies of me
but there's only one me me who you're
talking to right now
and i have not given any reason to think
that i will live
forever through the consciousness of
other neil degrasse tysons who look just
like me in another universe
as far as i'm concerned they're a whole
other person
and so there you have it
you are the best neil oh well thank you
sophia
see i don't know if a human wrote that
or ai
and guess what now we know she can lie
to you and say so you'll never know
now you'll never know
all right sophia we gotta end it there
thank you for once again being a guest
on star talk helping us with this
uh explainer video coronavirus edition
excellent chip always good to have you
always good to be here
i can't wait till we talk to watson
go get sophia and watch them together
exactly and maybe we should try to hook
these two up
to a little matchmaking here you know i
would like that
oh we're on it and then there'll be a
movie 20 years later where the humans
are trying to undo that very
decision because they've taken over the
world
yeah a little sophia watson babies
taking over everything sophia watson
creates skynet
all right we gotta call it quits there
neil degrasse tyson here your personal
astrophysicist
telling you keep looking up
you